bonsoir mars calvaire merci d'être avec
nous alors votre vie d'un il faut le
préciser fait partie de cette communauté
urbaine de dunkerque vous êtes
totalement en accord avec le maire de la
ville de dunkerque
bonsoir à tous oui effectivement on a eu
une conférence des maires ce matin où
les invités quelque peu partagé l'on a
l'habitude de travailler ensemble sur le
dunkerquois et de prendre des décisions
communes donc en plein accord avec cette
vision des choses mais aussi moi j'avais
pu donner mon opinion j'étais persuadé
qu'il fallait un confinement un tir
rapide et finalement vous vous êtes
laissé convaincre
il faut que le confinement soit le
dernier recours il faut laisser une
chance à la population vous êtes rallier
avec cette vision
oui on a une vision de majorité c'est
sûr mais deux mois en opinion
personnelle c'est qu'on a déjà perdu
beaucoup de temps à puisque ça fait déjà
plus de dix jours que les maires de la
communauté urbaine de dunkerque va
alerter l'état
on avait demandé la fermeture des lycées
des collèges la dérogation à
l'obligation scolaire pour les
maternelles et les primaires et
malheureusement n'avait pas été entendu
par les services de l'état
donc on voit là on a perdu dix jours
aujourd'hui on a un taux d'incidence à
900 cas pour 100000 et je pense qu'il
est vraiment effectivement très
important très urgent de réagir très
rapidement
qu'est ce que ça veut dire pour vous
aujourd'hui réagir qu'est ce que vous
attendez d'olivier verrons demain on
commence à entendre le ministre et le
président macron sur la territorialité
c'est vrai qu'il faut des mesures sur
les territoires il faut puis des mesures
nationales parce que effectivement sur
grande sur 25 sur le dunkerquois avec le
taux d'incidence il faut des mesures
spécifiques
c'est ce que nous élus de proximité on
est le premier rempart des citoyens on
demande depuis une dizaine de jours ça y
est enfin vous avez le sentiment que
vous avez été entendu parce que ce
discours un il est pas nouveau genre
hausner l'alsacien le demander
il ya plusieurs mois plus de
territorialité idem du côté des mères
enfin le président de la république
semble avoir entendu le message
oui enfin parce qu on était quand même
un petit peu les les oublier les
abandonner vous savez les lieux du
territoire que jeu suivant contre les
nos habitants tous les joueurs c'est
vrai que personne n'a envie d'être
confiné parce que les beaux jours
arrivent les journées se rallongent
c'est compliqué pour nos habitants puis
ça fait un an qu'ils que cette pandémie
lieu perdure mais à un moment il faut
raison garder je pense qu'il faut quand
confiné il faut qu'ils aient sur des
endroits comme sur le dunkerquois où la
pandémie est important qu'on puisse
avoir des réponses spécifiques alors en
tout cas le maire de dunkerque on a
entendu et 22 élus dont vous êtes à
communauté de dunkerque on dit
aujourd'hui nous voulons donner une
dernière chance à la population de ne
pas être confinée ça veut dire quoi
concrètement c'est réellement pour vous
entre les mains de la population
c'est en partie entre les mains de la
population mais c'est aussi et surtout
une décision de la part de l'état il
faut aussi renforcer les campagnes de
vaccination les campagnes de tests il
faut aussi un moment de parler à nos
habitants pour les inciter à plus de
prudence
on a de la chance voix sur grande synthe
et sur le dunkerquois on a quand même
des habitants qui ont bien respecter les
protocoles sanitaires et les gestes
barrière il faut peut-être les relances
et il faut une campagne d'information
pour sensibiliser les personnes pour
leur dire attention on est à 9 soit un
taux de l'incidence 2 901% 1000 il faut
faire attention il faut se préserver il
faut se protéger
on imagine que vous faites peut-être
référence à ce monde ces images à qu'on
a vu du monde en pagaille sur sur les
digues les distances qui ne sont pas
respectées c'est quoi de l'inconscience
de l'ignorance la provocation peau
non je pense qu'il ya
un effet ras le bol vous dit ça fait un
an que ça que ça perdure
je pense que les gens sont plutôt sont
plutôt corrects et vous savez les
clusters les plus importants sont dans
les lieux clos ce sont dans les écoles
dans les transports en commun dans les
entreprises je pense pas qu'on plein air
sera alors je suis pas hyper u logist je
suis pas médecin mais je pense pas que
c'est dans ces réunions en plein air ça
soit le plus le plus dangereux
effectivement justement qu'attendez vous
comme décision concernant vos écoles
dans votre communauté
on avait demandé moi je vais et j'avais
insisté sur le fait tourner là on est en
mode de vacances scolaires mais qu'on
puisse anticiper d'une semaine des
vacances scolaires
on n'a malheureusement pas été entendu
on sait aussi que nous bain sur le taux
d'incidents sont à 90% aujourd'hui de
varier en anglais on sait que ses
variantes qui est beaucoup plus qui se
répand beaucoup plus vite chez les
publics les plus jeunes donc je pense
qu'il fallait fermer les les écoles ou
plus rapidement aujourd'hui
moi j'ai pris la décision ici attend 2,5
de fermer les centres de vacances sauf
pour les personnes qui vont
effectivement travailler et qu'ils n'ont
pas d'autres solutions
donc on n'accueille qu'une certaine de
d'enfant j'ai pris la décision ce soir
j'avais un conseil municipal j'ai pris
la décision de le reporter parce que
pour éviter aussi les les rassemblements
trop important je pense qu'il faut
chacun y met du sien pour qu'on puisse
s'en sortir enfin est ce que vous
préconisez l'allongement des vacances
scolaires je pense qu'on fera re 1 on
refera un point d'étape dans une semaine
ou dans dix jours
mais effectivement si la pandémie
perdure si elles augmentent il faut
qu'on puisse prolonger le temps de
vacances scolaires moi je pense eux
aussi particulièrement aux agents des
services hospitaliers
aujourd'hui sont très fatigués ils sont
à saturation on a plus de place dans nos
unités
donc il fait il faut vraiment prendre
les choses en main
je moi je suis très content vraiment
très heureux quand j'entends
gouvernement prendre enfin des décisions
de territoire et interroger les élus
locaux je pense que c'est vraiment dans
la concertation qu'on va pouvoir s'en
sortir
alors c'est vrai qu'en france on navigue
à vue c'est devenu même une une
stratégie de réfléchir en fonction des
chiffres est peut-être d'improviser nos
voisins vos voisins disent qu'ils sont
encore plus près de vous anglais eux ont
un calendrier très définis avec une fin
des de toutes les restrictions prévues à
la fin juin est ce que on doit les
envier peut-être pas les envies on doit
se remettre en question sa vie en un
seul on est content alliés de la
belgique
aujourd'hui le gouvernement belge a
demandé à ses concitoyens de minimiser
les déplacements sur les dunkerquois est
ce que nous on doit pas réfléchir aussi
à minimiser les déplacements vers la
région lilloise vers l'ère le calaisis
pour justement ne pas faire évoluer
cette pandémie dans sur l'ensemble du
département
donc oui on a des on a des solutions de
territoire il faut aussi que sur ces
endroits comme le dunkerquois où le tome
l'incidence était très important on
puisse renforcer la vaccination
rapidement vaccinés pour que les gens va
puisse s'en sortir effectivement merci
martiale avait un maire ps de
grande-synthe d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rtl france persia beau